avec un spectacle et quelques sourires
c'est fou ce que l'on peut faire pour
des enfants à l'hôpital
à quelques jours de noël en guise de
cadeau avant l'heure une centaine
d'entre eux a pu profiter d'une
animation à l'hôpital du chesnay
histoire de délaisser soucis et problème
l'espace de quelques instants
c'est pour les petits sortir du
quotidien médical vraiment en fait
côté affectif plutôt que côté maladie
l'objectif c'est de prendre un petit peu
la vie plus sereine meilleur à tous ces
gens qui ont eu un pépin quoi si vous
voulez et pour faire sourire ses enfants
à l'hôpital parce qu'à la cie auteur
compositeur habitué des performances
pour les plus jeunes propose un
spectacle tout en musique et en chansons
et là je savais qu'on peut faire dès
hier les dettes d'ici c'est aussi un
spectacle comme un autre mais parfois on
est pris par surprise par l'émotion
parce qu'il va se dérouler un événement
inattendu différents proposés par
l'association rire 78 depuis dix ans
l'opération rire pour guérir est aussi
un temps pour le corps médical
un temps qui permet de créer un lien
différent et rassurant pour les enfants
de voir que les soignants peuvent
proposer un spectacle
e
de proposer
enfin de voir les soignants sourire et
rire et nous aussi de connaître les
parents et de voir les enfants sourire
et rire ça nous fait ça fait du bien à
tout le monde tous les ans rires 78
propose une dizaine de spectacles dans
les hôpitaux yvelinois des parenthèse
heureuse pour tenter de vaincre la
maladie